Instacart knows that some people go bananas about getting the perfect, well, banana. Some want them green. Some want them ripe. Some want them ready right when they hit their doorstep. But with Instacart's preference picker, available at most retailers, you can choose to get your groceries just the way you like. That means perfectly ripe bananas. Deli meat sliced just the way you want.
Instacart知道有些人为了得到完美的香蕉会变得非常疯狂。有些人喜欢绿的，有些人喜欢熟的，有些人希望香蕉送到家门口时刚好能吃。但通过Instacart的偏好选择功能（大多数零售商都提供此功能），你可以选择以自己喜欢的方式购买杂货。这意味着你可以买到熟度完美的香蕉，或者按你要求切好的熟食肉。
And avocados that aren't still hard as a puck in the third period. So don't cross your fingers and hope for the best. Download the app and get groceries just how you like with Instacart. Welcome to your second drink of Weight Loss Part 2. Jenna, you had a soapbox in this episode. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. We got this letter from Tara M.
还有那些在第三节比赛时还没像冰球一样硬的牛油果。所以，别再祈祷运气了。下载App，用Instacart按你的喜好购买杂货吧。欢迎收听《减肥（下）》的第二部分。Jenna，这一集里你有一个“肥皂箱”时刻。嗯哼。嗯哼。我们收到了Tara M.的来信。
Jenna, I just wanted you to know that I was so with you today on Part 2 when you talked about all the hate pamph gets. It's absolutely 100% sexism. Thank you so much for saying so. I support you and love you both so much. Well, thank you, Tara. I am aware that by Soapbox from this episode created a lot of debate of people arguing back and forth, but I think I help some people see things in a new way. And now, you know, 15 years later, people are really seeing the Jim Pam situation a little differently. You know, some of the things that were seen as romantic 15 years ago, they hit a little different now. Like, maybe it's not. so romantic to surprise your wife by buying a house. Maybe it's not neat to invest your savings and take a job out of town at a startup without telling her when you have two small kids whose care is all going to fall to her. When you say that out loud, that's like, what?
Jenna，我只是想让你知道，今天在第二部分里，当你谈到Pam遭受的所有仇恨时，我非常支持你。这绝对是100%的性别歧视。非常感谢你这么说。我支持你们，也非常爱你们俩。好吧，谢谢你，Tara。我知道我在这一集里的“肥皂箱”言论引发了很多争论，人们各执一词，但我认为我帮助一些人以新的方式看待问题了。现在，15年过去了，人们确实对Jim和Pam的情况有了不同的看法。你知道，15年前被视为浪漫的一些事情，现在看来感觉有点不同了。比如，给妻子买房子作为惊喜可能并不那么浪漫。也许在有两个小孩、所有照顾责任都落在她身上时，不告诉她就投资积蓄并去外地创业，这并不算体贴。当你大声说出来时，你会觉得，什么？
You took our savings? You got a job out of town? Like we didn't talk this out? With like an insecure startup. Yeah. And he doesn't tell her for weeks. I know. It's like Darrell has to convince him to be like, are you going to tell Pam? Like, we're leaving for Philly soon. Like, when are you going to bring her in the loop? So I think it's hitting a little differently now with this younger generation that's watching The Office. And those folks are like, I think maybe Pam's right to be a little grumpy.
你拿走了我们的积蓄？你去外地找了份工作？我们难道没有商量过吗？而且还是去一家不稳定的初创公司。是的。而且他几周都没告诉她。我知道。就像Darrell不得不说服他，问他：“你打算告诉Pam吗？我们很快就要去费城了。你打算什么时候让她知道？”所以我认为现在的年轻一代在看《办公室》时，感觉确实有点不同了。那些观众会觉得，也许Pam有点脾气是正确的。
Yeah. Like, it's not unsupportive to be annoyed that your partner did something. But, yeah, when the episode first aired, I got a lot of shit for it. And it reminds me, too, I recently did a rewatch of Breaking Bad. Do you remember when Breaking Bad first came out, Anna Gun, the actress who played Skyler White, you know, married to Walter White. Yeah. She got a lot of shit for, like, how hurt and upset she was that her husband was becoming
是的。因为对伴侣做的事情感到恼火并不是不支持对方。但是，是的，当这一集刚播出时，我因此受到了很多抨击。这也让我想起，我最近重温了《绝命毒师》。你还记得《绝命毒师》刚出来的时候吗？饰演Skyler White的演员Anna Gunn，你知道，就是Walter White的妻子。是的。她因为对丈夫变成……
a methamphetamine drug kingpin. She didn't have space in her heart for that. And it's interesting because when I rewatched it, I was like, oh my God, she was, like, I thought her performance is just like spot on. Could you imagine? Could you imagine? But everybody was so dazzled by the charismatic Walter White. They were pissed that she wasn't more supportive. That's so wild.
一个冰毒大毒枭感到受伤和不安，而受到了很多抨击。她心里没有空间去容忍那个。这很有趣，因为当我重温时，我觉得，天哪，她的表演简直太到位了。你能想象吗？你能想象吗？但每个人都被魅力四射的Walter White迷住了。他们对她不够支持感到愤怒。这太疯狂了。
Okay. So I also talked about an amazing deleted scene with Ryan getting yelled at by David Wallace. David is so mad when he calls and Ryan answers the phone. You know, Ryan was stealing from the company. What the hell? Now he's answering the phones again? There's this great scene with Michael on the phone with David, and I brought it up in our breakdown.
好了。我还谈到了一个精彩的删减片段，Ryan被David Wallace大骂。David打电话时Ryan接了电话，他非常生气。你知道，Ryan一直在偷公司的钱。搞什么鬼？现在他又在接电话了？有一个很棒的场景是Michael和David通电话，我在我们的解析中提到了。
It's been added back to the superfan episode, and I just wanted everyone to hear it. I want him out of the building now. Allegedly. No, not allegedly. As part of his plea, he admitted his guilt. Allegedly admitted his guilt. What?
它被加回了超级粉丝版剧集中，我只是想让大家听听。我现在就要他滚出这栋大楼。据称。不，不是据称。作为认罪协议的一部分，他承认了自己的罪行。据称承认了自己的罪行。什么？
Listen, David. I know Ryan. Michael. He is good people. He made a huge, huge error. I just, I think he needs direction. That's all. I'm tired, Michael.
听着，David。我了解Ryan。Michael。他是好人。他犯了一个巨大的、巨大的错误。我只是觉得他需要指导。仅此而已。我累了，Michael。
Me too. Okay. With all my heart, yes. Fine. He can't talk to clients? On me. What do I have to do with it? I mean, this guy is a criminal record.
我也是。好吧。我全心全意地同意。好吧。他不能和客户交谈？由我负责？这跟我有什么关系？我的意思是，这家伙有犯罪记录。
I think that's a little excessive. Whoa, wait. On me? Yes, Michael, you brought him. back. Amazing. It's so good. And Andy Buckley's so great in that scene. Well, listen, I have one last letter to share. It's from Megan M. who says, hey, I found a little error in the last office ladies' episode. Jenna and Angela said that Kelly had the same nameplate that she was gifted in the office Christmas party episode. But upon looking at it, it's a different plate. The one in the
我觉得这有点过分了。哇，等等。由我负责？是的，Michael，是你把他带回来的。太棒了。这太好了。Andy Buckley在那个场景里演得太棒了。好吧，听着，我还有最后一封信要分享。来自Megan M.，她说，嘿，我在上一集《办公室女士》中发现了一个小错误。Jenna和Angela说Kelly的名牌和她在《办公室圣诞派对》那一集中收到的是同一个。但仔细一看，那是不同的牌子。那个在……
Christmas episode is purple with seven orange, blue and pink stemless, daisy-ish flower. And but the plate on her desk in this episode is different. It's metallic, and there are only two red flowers with stems. So it's a floral plate, but not the same one that was gifted to her in Christmas party. Huh. Well, lady, you know what I did. Asa bas-ab. You know I did.
圣诞那一集里的是紫色的，上面有七朵橙色、蓝色和粉色的无茎雏菊状花朵。但这一集她桌上的牌子不一样。它是金属质感的，只有两朵带茎的红花。所以它确实是一个花卉牌子，但不是圣诞派对上送给她的那个。哈。好吧，女士，你知道我做了什么。Asa bas-ab。你知道我做了什么。
Look, there it is. It's different. Oh, my goodness. Megan, you're so right. Megan is right. Clearly there is a theme here, and that is fancy font with flowers. But they're totally different. Totally different.
看，就在那儿。它是不一样的。天哪。Megan，你说得太对了。Megan是对的。显然这里有一个主题，那就是花哨的字体配上花朵。但它们完全不同。完全不同。
And Megan, thank you for giving me the opportunity to do a side-by-side, which you know is one of my favorite things to do. All right, you guys, here is your second drink of weight loss, part two. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of the Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there.
Megan，谢谢你给我机会做一个并排对比，你知道这是我最喜欢做的事情之一。好了，各位，这就是《减肥（下）》的第二部分。我是Jenna Fisher。我是Angela Kinsey。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能讲出的独家幕后故事。
can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hey gang, how's it going? Howdy. It is Weight Loss Part 2. Season 5. Yeah. This is the second part of our season 5 premiere. It was written by Lee Eisenberg and Gene Stubnitsky and directed by Paul Feig. Hit us with a summary. All right. Well, you might remember last week we set up that Dunder Mifflin is doing a company-wide weight loss contest.
我们是办公室女士。嘿，伙计们，最近怎么样？你好。这是《减肥（下）》。第五季。是的。这是我们第五季首播的第二部分。由Lee Eisenberg和Gene Stupnitsky编剧，Paul Feig执导。给我们一个总结吧。好的，你们可能还记得上周我们提到Dunder Mifflin正在进行一场全公司范围的减肥比赛。
That contest continues. It's really causing some division among the employees. People are getting hungry. They are. Ryan returns to Scranton. He's a temp again. Michael hires him to fill in at reception for Pam, who is off at Pratt. She's, you know, doing art school.
那场比赛还在继续。它确实在员工之间造成了一些分歧。人们开始感到饥饿了。确实。Ryan回到了Scranton。他又成了临时工。Michael雇他来接替Pam在接待处的工作，因为Pam去了Pratt。她正在，你知道，上艺术学校。
Now Michael is very slowly still pursuing Holly. Dwight and Angela are continuing to hook up in the warehouse behind Andy's back. And Jim has an important question for Pam. The question! All right. Fast fact number one. Paul Feig directed this episode, and he also had a much larger role overall in season five. Paul was with us for every single episode of season five.
现在Michael还在非常缓慢地追求Holly。Dwight和Angela继续在仓库里背着Andy偷情。Jim有一个重要的问题要问Pam。那个问题！好了，第一个速记事实。Paul Feig执导了这一集，他在第五季中整体上也扮演了更重要的角色。Paul在第五季的每一集都和我们在一起。
He was, and he was amazing. He was this great constant, like, I don't know, Jen, he was like the man of the ship. He was like guiding us along the way, having his. on set always just made me feel better. I'm with you. I loved it. You remember last week we talked about how Greg Daniels was now working on both the office and he was trying to get parks and wreck off the ground. He had groomed Jen Salada and Paul Lieberstein to run the show. They were overseeing the writing of the show. They were running the writer's room. Well, Paul Feig was brought on as a supervising director and co-executive producer to oversee the on-set production
是的，他太棒了。他是一个伟大的常驻人物，就像，我不知道，Jen，他就像这艘船的船长。他指引着我们前进，他在片场总是让我感觉更好。我同意你的看法。我喜欢这样。你还记得上周我们谈到Greg Daniels现在同时在忙《办公室》和《公园与游憩》的筹备工作吗？他培养了Jen Salada和Paul Lieberstein来管理节目。他们负责监督剧本创作，管理编剧室。而Paul Feig被聘为监制导演和联合执行制片人，负责监督现场制作……
and to oversee all of our directors. Because we had a lot of new directors in season five, including some cast members and crew members and even some of our writers. They all directed their first episodes. Paul was also in the writers' room a bit, but mostly he was like the tastemaker, right? He was like one of these original visionaries.
并监督我们所有的导演。因为我们在第五季有很多新导演，包括一些演员、剧组成员，甚至是我们的一些编剧。他们都执导了自己的第一集。Paul也偶尔在编剧室，但他主要是那个“品味塑造者”，对吧？他就像最初的远见者之一。
What is a taste maker? I mean, I don't know, but I think a tastemaker is like you, set the tastes of... Did you make up that word? No, tastemaker's a real word. Well, maybe if you're, like, running a winery. But you can be like a tastemaker-like is the same as like a...
什么是品味塑造者？我的意思是，我不知道，但我认为品味塑造者就像你，设定了……你是编造了这个词吗？不，品味塑造者是一个真正的词。好吧，也许如果你是在经营一家酒庄的话。但你可以说品味塑造者就像一个……
I think you made it up. Well, I didn't. You can Google it. I can't believe you're getting out your phone right now to Google it. This is unbelievable. Taste maker is a real word. It's like a trendsetter. Yes. Thank you, Sam. It's like a trendsetter. Okay.
我觉得是你编出来的。好吧，我没有。你可以谷歌一下。我不敢相信你现在拿出手机去谷歌它。这太不可思议了。品味塑造者是一个真正的词。它就像一个潮流引领者。是的。谢谢你，Sam。它就像一个潮流引领者。好吧。
Tastemaker. Okay. According to the English language learner's definition, a person whose judgment about what is good, fashionable, et cetera, are accepted and followed by many other people. That's right. He was a taste maker. He was a taste maker. He was. It was his job to control the quality of the show. You know, he said yes to jokes and no to other jokes because of his good taste. I know this is getting us off so early. I really want to know the origin of this word. Like, where did the word tastemaker come from? Was that the person that, like, tried the food for the king? And if he didn't die, okay, fine. We'll all eat what that guy had? I don't know, but I think you should deep dive it for a revisit it, Angela. Okay, fine. I do. Okay. Paul Fieg was the tastemaker. Wow. You know what just happened there, Angela. What? You just got real hot and bothered with me. I did not. You did. That is not hot and bothered. That is purplored. That is purplored. that is perplexed and curious and you were right there you were right you were real you were right you were real hot to trot
品味塑造者。好吧。根据英语学习者的定义，一个对什么是好的、时尚的等方面的判断被许多其他人接受和追随的人。没错。他是一个品味塑造者。他是一个品味塑造者。他确实是。他的工作是控制节目的质量。你知道，因为他品味好，所以他对一些笑话说是，对另一些笑话说不。我知道这让我们偏离主题太早了。我真的很想知道这个词的起源。比如，品味塑造者这个词是从哪里来的？那是为国王试吃食物的人吗？如果他没死，好吧，那我们就都吃那个人吃的东西？我不知道，但我认为你应该深入研究一下，Angela。好吧，好吧。我会的。好吧。Paul Feig是品味塑造者。哇。你知道刚才发生了什么吗，Angela。什么？你刚才对我变得非常激动和困扰。我没有。你有了。那不是激动和困扰。那是困惑。那是困惑和好奇，你就在那儿，你就在那儿，你真的很……
that means wanting sex i know what that means now all right well listen i talked to gregg daniels about it and he said that this was a big push that he had to make with the network in particular jerry de canio the head of production at universal because our show had been functioning just fine without someone in this role before. But Greg explained he was often called down to set to discuss the shooting or the motivations with the actors and directors, and he wanted to make sure that that would still be covered
那意味着想要性，我知道那是什么意思。好了，听着，我和Greg Daniels谈过这件事，他说这是他必须向电视网，特别是环球影业制作主管Jerry DeCanio推动的一项重大举措，因为我们的节目在之前没有这个角色时一直运行得很好。但Greg解释说，他经常被叫到片场讨论拍摄或演员和导演的动机，他想确保在他离开时这些工作仍然能得到覆盖。
while he was gone. And they eventually agreed. And I traded some messages with Paul Figue about this too. And he even sent in an audio clip. Oh, Paul Figue. All the way from London. Yep. It was such a fun year because,
他们最终同意了。我也和Paul Feig交换了一些关于这件事的信息。他甚至发来了一段音频片段。哦，Paul Feig。远在伦敦。是的。那真是快乐的一年，因为……
You know, to be around you guys in the cast every day and to be in that writer's room with that amazing group of writers. Was just such a special opportunity. Yeah, I got to direct a lot of episodes that season, but also it was just fun to kind of be with all these other people who were starting to direct and seeing how great they were doing. It was so fun to be with Steve when he directed his first episode. And Brent Forrester did a great job. And Dave Rogers, we had so much fun. And so that was kind of my experience of the fifth season was being around everybody. so much, but also just kind of getting to see the show through a lot of fresh eyes of these new
你知道，每天和你们这些演员在一起，和那群了不起的编剧在编剧室里，真是一个特别的机会。是的，那一季我执导了很多集，但能和所有这些开始执导的人在一起，看到他们做得有多棒，也很有趣。能和Steve一起执导他的第一集真是太有趣了。Brent Forrester做得很好。Dave Rogers，我们玩得很开心。所以这就是我第五季的经历，和大家在一起，但也看到了很多新导演或第一次做这件事的人带来的新鲜视角。
directors or people coming on and doing it for the first time. Well, I want to say that Paul also directed five episodes himself this season. And when we were trading messages, Angela, he said he loved his time on season five so much that he wanted to send us audio clips for every single episode of season five. Get out. With his memories. Paulopedia. I was like, Paul, you're busy.
好吧，我想说Paul这一季自己也执导了五集。当我们交换信息时，Angela，他说他非常喜欢在第五季的时光，以至于他想为第五季的每一集都给我们发音频片段。别开玩笑了。带着他的回忆。Paulopedia。我说，Paul，你很忙。
You're directing a movie right now in London. I mean, you don't have to do that. And he said, well, I'll do as many as I can. So guys, get ready. Get ready for, should it be figopedia or polypedia? Paul Figopedia? Paul Figopedia. All right.
你现在在伦敦执导一部电影。我的意思是，你不必那样做。他说，好吧，我会尽我所能做尽可能多的。所以伙计们，准备好。准备好迎接，应该是Figopedia还是Polypedia？Paul Figopedia？Paul Figopedia。好了。
Fast fact number two is an art school location breakdown. We didn't do this last week. We're going to see more of art school. this week, so I thought it was appropriate. Okay. Fan question from Yvette and Rachel. Where were the New York City art school scenes shot? I will tell you.
第二个速记事实是艺术学校的地点解析。我们上周没做这个。我们这周会看到更多艺术学校的场景，所以我认为这很合适。好的。来自Yvette和Rachel的粉丝提问。纽约市艺术学校的场景是在哪里拍摄的？我会告诉你们。
Mm-hmm. Everything was shot at USC, the University of Southern California. The classrooms were empty classrooms on campus that are set decorators dressed. Even the dorm room was a USC dorm room. The hallways, when Jim's watching TV in the common room, we were basically all on campus. The only thing we didn't shoot on campus, and we talked about this last week, was when Jim and Pam are video chatting. They recreated my dorm room on that warehouse set of Dunder Mifflin. Well, I have one other thing to share about the USC campus, but I am going to save it when it comes up in the episode.
嗯哼。所有场景都是在南加州大学（USC）拍摄的。教室是校园里的空教室，由布景师装饰。连宿舍也是USC的宿舍。走廊，当Jim在公共休息室看电视时，我们基本上都在校园里。我们唯一没有在校园里拍摄的，我们上周谈过，是Jim和Pam视频聊天的时候。他们在Dunder Mifflin的仓库布景里重建了我的宿舍。好吧，关于USC校园我还有一件事要分享，但我会留到它在这一集中出现时再说。
Well, all right. I have one fun thing to share about the real Pratt, which is in Brooklyn. That's where Pam's meant to be. We got a letter from Mila S, who is a student at Pratt, and she said this. There is a communal cat population living on campus called Pratt Cats. They have their own little houses, and they wander the lecture halls and the campus freely. If you're ever in New York, I highly recommend you visit the campus, along with its sculptures and cats roaming the grounds. Angela, the cats even have their own Instagram page, and it's called Pratt Cats.
好吧，好吧。关于真正的Pratt，我有一件有趣的事要分享，它在布鲁克林。那是Pam应该在的地方。我们收到了Mila S.的来信，她是Pratt的学生，她说：校园里住着一群社区猫，叫Pratt Cats。它们有自己的小房子，在演讲厅和校园里自由漫步。如果你去纽约，我强烈建议你参观一下校园，还有那些在地上漫步的雕塑和猫。Angela，这些猫甚至有自己的Instagram页面，叫Pratt Cats。
Prat cats! That's so cute! Two T's for Pratt and two T's for cats. Pratt Cats. Prat cats. I looked at it. It's just a lot of super cute pictures of cats. I want to see it. Oh my gosh. There's so many. Yeah. I wonder who does the Instagram. There's so many cats. I think we should put this on our list. We should. All right. Fast fact number three, we've got a big guest star alert. It's Rich Summer as Pam's art school friend Alex. Yes. And we are friends with Rich. We're like really good friends with Rich. He needs to be. He needs to
Pratt Cats！太可爱了！Pratt有两个T，Cats有两个T。Pratt Cats。Pratt Cats。我看过了。上面有很多超级可爱的猫的照片。我想看。天哪。有这么多。是的。我想知道是谁在运营那个Instagram。有这么多猫。我觉得我们应该把它列入我们的清单。我们应该这样做。好了。第三个速记事实，我们有一个大牌客串明星预警。是Rich Summer，饰演Pam的艺术学校朋友Alex。是的。我们和Rich是朋友。我们和Rich关系非常好。他需要……
to come on. Well, he's refused. No, he has not. I'm kidding. We are going to have him on. You guys, Rich is probably most well known for his role as Harry Crane on Mad Men, but he's also acted in such shows as Wet Hot American Summer, the TV series, as well as many movies with Office Connections. Oh, yeah. He was in The Devil Wears Prada starring Emily Blunt. He was in Celeste and Jesse Forever starring Rashida Jones. And he was in the giant mechanical man starring me. Yay! He is also supposedly real-life friends with Nicholas Degosto, aka Hunter. We're going to have to ask him about that when he comes on the show. Oh yeah. We have lots to ask him. We do. Jenna, as you remember from last week, there is a fantastic DVD commentary for weight loss.
来参加节目。好吧，他拒绝了。不，他没有。我开玩笑的。我们会邀请他来的。伙计们，Rich可能最出名的是他在《广告狂人》中饰演Harry Crane的角色，但他还出演过《湿热夏令营》电视剧，以及许多与《办公室》有联系的电影。哦，是的。他出演了Emily Blunt主演的《穿普拉达的女王》。他出演了Rashida Jones主演的《离婚不分手》。他还出演了我主演的《巨人机械人》。耶！他还据说是Nicholas D'Agosto（也就是Hunter）的现实生活中的朋友。我们得在他上节目时问问他。哦，是的。我们有很多问题要问他。我们会的。Jenna，正如你从上周记得的那样，关于《减肥》有一段精彩的DVD评论。
It's an all-cru DVD commentary. I have more to share from that in this week's Weight Loss Part 2, as well as I reached out to Joya Balfour. Do you guys remember Joya? She has contributed information on the podcast before. She worked on the digital team at NBC.com, and she has some fun Andy Angela Wedding stuff that she shared with me as well as one little surprise, but we'll get to it. I love it. Should we take a break and then we'll be back?
那是全剧组的DVD评论。关于本周的《减肥（下）》，我还有更多要分享的，而且我联系了Joya Balfour。你们还记得Joya吗？她之前为播客贡献过信息。她在NBC.com的数字团队工作，她分享了一些关于Andy和Angela婚礼的有趣内容，还有一个小惊喜，但我们稍后再说。我喜欢这个。我们要休息一下，然后回来吗？
Yeah. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, we are going to take a moment to celebrate women and all the that they carry at work, in relationships, and families, and in the many roles they hold every single day. And we need to remind ourselves about how much we matter, and that therapy offers a space for us to take care of ourselves in the way we deserve. Therapy can also be a place to set boundaries and build confidence. Just take care of your own well-being for a change. Better help makes therapy accessible and flexible. Their therapists are fully licensed in the U.S.
是的。本节目由BetterHelp赞助。你知道，我们要花点时间赞美女性，赞美她们在工作、人际关系、家庭以及她们每天扮演的许多角色中所承担的一切。我们需要提醒自己我们有多重要，治疗为我们提供了一个空间，让我们以应有的方式照顾自己。治疗也可以是一个设定界限和建立自信的地方。为了改变，照顾好你自己的幸福吧。BetterHelp让治疗变得触手可及且灵活。他们的治疗师在美国拥有完全执照。
and follow a strict code of conduct. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, and it works, with an average rating of 4.9 out of 5 for a live session based on over 1.7 million client reviews. Your emotional well-being matters. Find support and feel lighter in therapy. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's better, h-elp.com slash office ladies. Have you ever felt like you were a little? living just a B or B plus life, it's so dangerous to live that.
并遵循严格的行为准则。BetterHelp拥有超过30,000名治疗师，是世界上最大的在线治疗平台，而且它很有效，基于超过170万条客户评论，直播课程的平均评分为4.9/5。你的情感健康很重要。在治疗中寻找支持，感觉更轻松。注册并在BetterHelp.com/officeladies获得10%的折扣。那是better, h-elp.com/officeladies。你有没有觉得你有点……只过着B或B+的生活，过这种生活太危险了。
More dangerous than a B minus or a C plus life, because when you're living a B or B plus life, you don't change it. You think it's good enough. Is it? I'm Susie Welch. I host a podcast called Becoming You. People think, okay, an A plus life is not available to me, but there is a way. We are all in the process of becoming ourselves.
比B-或C+的生活更危险，因为当你过着B或B+的生活时，你不会改变它。你认为这已经足够好了。是吗？我是Susie Welch。我主持一个叫《Becoming You》的播客。人们认为，好吧，A+的生活对我来说是不可能的，但有一种方法。我们都在成为自己的过程中。
Listen to Becoming You wherever you get your podcasts. We're back. And a friendly Ryan has returned to Dunder Mifflin Scranton. There is a deleted scene, Jenna, that the camera catches Ryan being dropped off to work by his mother. She's driving a station wagon. She pulls up, he hops out with a little sack lunch, and he starts to go in the building, and she rolls down the window and honks her horn. And he runs back and gives her a kiss on the cheek, and then he runs in the building.
在任何你获取播客的地方收听《Becoming You》。我们回来了。友好的Ryan回到了Dunder Mifflin Scranton。Jenna，有一个删减片段，摄像机捕捉到Ryan被他母亲开车送到公司。她开着一辆旅行车。她停下车，他带着一个小午餐袋跳下车，开始走进大楼，她摇下车窗按喇叭。他跑回去在她脸颊上亲了一下，然后跑进大楼。
Wow. If this tells you where Ryan is at at life, he's back living at home and his mom is driving him to work. Wow. He's also grown a goate. And this now explains why Michael has had a goate because he says, Michael, did you grow that goatee after you saw mine when you helped me move? Yeah. Remember, these goatees are not real. Hair and makeup put them on. I thought they did a fantastic job. job and Michael has a talking head that explains that he hired Ryan off the temp agency. Yeah. He said Ronnie was very blech and he told the temp agency, I don't care what it costs me. I have to have him. I have to have Ryan Howard. People don't know how to react to Ryan being back. Kevin is excited, runs over, gives him a nuggie, which starts a great runner. And Jenna, there was more in the deleted scenes of Ryan having these talking heads where he's putting everyone who's wronged him on his list.
哇。如果这能说明Ryan的生活状态，他搬回家住了，他妈妈开车送他上班。哇。他还留了山羊胡。这现在解释了为什么Michael也留了山羊胡，因为他说：“Michael，你是在看到我的山羊胡后才留的吗？当你帮我搬家的时候？”是的。记住，这些山羊胡不是真的。发型和化妆部门给他们贴上的。我觉得他们做得非常棒。而且Michael有一个谈话头片段解释了他从临时工中介雇佣了Ryan。是的。他说Ronnie非常平庸，他告诉临时工中介，我不在乎花多少钱。我必须拥有他。我必须拥有Ryan Howard。人们不知道该如何反应Ryan的回归。Kevin很兴奋，跑过去给了他一个锁喉，这开启了一个很棒的梗。而且Jenna，在删减片段里还有更多Ryan的谈话头片段，他把所有冤枉过他的人都写在了他的名单上。
Yeah. He explains that he's making a list of everyone who wrongs him so that when he is back up on the top, he can get his revenge. Yeah. And Kevin just made the list. Also who makes the list is David Wallace. In a deleted scene, David Wallace calls. Ryan answers and David flips out, starts braille Aiding Ryan, you can hear it, you know, through the phone. Yeah. So much so that Ryan cries. And Michael vouches for Ryan, and David Wallace does not want him there, but agrees. And so now David Wallace has made the list.
是的。他解释说他正在列出一份所有冤枉过他的人的名单，这样当他重回巅峰时，他就可以报仇了。是的。Kevin刚刚上了名单。同样上名单的还有David Wallace。在一个删减片段中，David Wallace打电话来。Ryan接了电话，David大发雷霆，开始通过电话大骂Ryan。是的。以至于Ryan哭了。Michael为Ryan担保，David Wallace不想让他待在那里，但同意了。所以现在David Wallace上了名单。
And Jenna, I couldn't help myself. You know what this made me think of. What? Game of Thrones. Oh, somebody has a list. I didn't get that far. Arias Stark has a kill list for everyone who's wronged her. Can we take a minute, everybody, if you haven't seen Game of Thrones and you don't want spoilers?
而且Jenna，我忍不住了。你知道这让我想到了什么吗。什么？《权力的游戏》。哦，有人有一份名单。我没看那么远。Arya Stark有一份杀人名单，上面写着所有冤枉过她的人。大家能花一分钟吗，如果你没看过《权力的游戏》而且不想被剧透？
Just, I don't know. Fast forward 30 seconds. Angela, I started Game of Thrones. I never finished it. I'm never going to finish it. Really? Will you just tell me, does Aria ever kill? She kills everybody. She does. She kills everybody and she kills the biggest baddie. And I don't want to ruin it in case someone didn't fast forward. But she kind of saves the whole world. I'll just say that. That is kind of a spoiler. That was the only thing that was kind of keeping me there was that I saw the potential in her character. No, she follows through. Well, that's good to know. Continuing Ryan's list, Ryan apologizes to Jim, right? Jim shakes his hand.
只是，我不知道。快进30秒。Angela，我开始看《权力的游戏》了。我从没看完。我永远也不会看完。真的吗？你能不能告诉我，Arya最后杀了吗？她杀了所有人。她确实杀了。她杀了所有人，还杀了最大的反派。我不想剧透，以防有人没快进。但她算是拯救了整个世界。我只能说这么多。那确实算剧透。那是唯一让我坚持看下去的东西，因为我看到了她角色的潜力。不，她坚持到底了。好吧，那很高兴知道。继续Ryan的名单，Ryan向Jim道歉，对吧？Jim和他握手。
And now are you ready for some Jim Sass? Oh, it's so good, though. Ready? Ryan says, Jim, I want to apologize for how I treated you last. year. He goes on to explain all the things he feels sorry for. And he said, you know, he's even started volunteering. He's giving back to the community. And Jim goes, well, that's great. You're talking about your court-ordered community service. And Ryan says, I don't need a judge to tell me to keep my community clean. And then Jim goes, but he did, right? And Ryan goes, all right. And Jim goes, all right.
现在你准备好迎接一些Jim的毒舌了吗？哦，太棒了。准备好了吗？Ryan说：“Jim，我想为我去年对待你的方式道歉。”他继续解释他感到抱歉的所有事情。他说，你知道，他甚至开始做志愿者了。他在回馈社区。Jim说：“哦，那太棒了。你说的是你法院判决的社区服务吗？”Ryan说：“我不需要法官告诉我保持社区清洁。”然后Jim说：“但他确实说了，对吧？”Ryan说：“好吧。”Jim说：“好吧。”
So much Jimsass. And then there's just a silent. Ryan talking head, where he's staring down the lens of the camera and he's clearly writing Jim Halpert in his list. Yeah. Which I loved. It's time for another way in on the giant scale that was custom made for our show we learned last week. There is a zero pound weight loss. People are really starting to melt down. Mm-hmm. 22 minutes, 59 seconds. Did anyone catch that Meredith's face is back to normal? Oh, I didn't catch that. Yeah, no more sunburn on Meredith. I'll tell you, we had Aaron M. write in and say, during that moment of the way in, Michael does this bird-like flapping move when he's frustrated. And she says it's literally my favorite moment in the whole show. She wants to know if Steve improvised that. Yes, that was not scripted. That was Steve's take on his character's frustration. I loved it so much. At 23 minutes, 21 seconds, Andy has a talking head. He says, this is the hardest thing he's ever had to do. And, you know, he hasn't had a very hard life.
太多的Jim毒舌了。然后是一个沉默的Ryan谈话头片段，他盯着摄像机镜头，显然在把Jim Halpert写进他的名单里。是的。我很喜欢这个。是时候再次称重了，我们上周了解到那是为我们的节目定制的巨型秤。零磅减肥。人们真的开始崩溃了。嗯哼。22分59秒。有人注意到Meredith的脸恢复正常了吗？哦，我没注意到。是的，Meredith不再晒伤了。我告诉你，我们收到了Aaron M.的来信，说在称重的那一刻，Michael在沮丧时做了这个像鸟一样的拍打动作。她说这简直是我整部剧里最喜欢的时刻。她想知道这是不是Steve即兴发挥的。是的，那不是剧本写的。那是Steve对他角色沮丧情绪的诠释。我太喜欢了。在23分21秒，Andy有一个谈话头片段。他说这是他做过的最难的事情。而且，你知道，他并没有过过非常艰难的生活。
Ding, ding, ding, ding. This was a digitally corrected shirt and tie. Once again, we talked about this in the episode previously, Weight Loss 1, that the writers wanted to move around some of Andy's talking heads. And to match his outfits for continuity, they had to go in in post-production, change the color of his tie and his shirt. I mean, it just blows my mind still. I know. Some other things that happened in the scene are that Holly tells Oscar that her date went well with his yoga instructor. And Mike, Michael overhears and then he blames Jim because he thinks Jim's bad advice has landed him in the friend zone with Holly. Mm-hmm. And then we move upstairs. Yeah. Dwight is really mad. He doesn't think everyone's taking this seriously.
叮，叮，叮，叮。这是一件经过数字修正的衬衫和领带。再一次，我们在上一集《减肥（上）》中谈到过，编剧们想调整Andy的一些谈话头片段。为了匹配他的服装以保持连贯性，他们必须在后期制作中改变他的领带和衬衫的颜色。我的意思是，这仍然让我感到震惊。我知道。在这个场景中发生的其他事情是，Holly告诉Oscar她的约会和他的瑜伽教练进行得很顺利。Michael无意中听到了，然后他责怪Jim，因为他认为Jim糟糕的建议让他陷入了与Holly的“朋友区”。嗯哼。然后我们上楼了。是的。Dwight真的很生气。他不认为每个人都在认真对待这件事。
He randomly selects Stanley, Phyllis, and Kevin and tells them to get liposection on their own dime. Yeah, they have to pay for it. Yeah. And meanwhile, Ryan goes to apologize to Kelly. And now we have some Kelly sass. Oh, it's so satisfying. I mean, Ryan, come on. I wish you could have stuck to it.
他随机挑选了Stanley、Phyllis和Kevin，告诉他们自费去做抽脂手术。是的，他们必须自己付钱。是的。与此同时，Ryan去向Kelly道歉。现在我们有一些Kelly的毒舌了。哦，太令人满足了。我的意思是，Ryan，拜托。我希望你能坚持下去。
I know. It's so good. He's like, hey, should we, you know, grab a drink later, catch up. And then he says, pick me up at eight, right? He's trying to do his old shenanigans with her. And she goes, that is so sweet. But I'm dating Daryl still and we're like crazy in love. So.
我知道。太棒了。他说：“嘿，我们稍后去喝一杯，叙叙旧怎么样？”然后他说：“八点来接我，好吗？”他试图对她耍他以前的那些花招。她说：“那太甜了。但我还在和Darrell约会，我们爱得疯狂。”所以。
And he goes, oh, cool. Well, maybe I'll see you around. And Kelly goes, it's a small office. Yeah. Yeah. Did you notice on her desk? What? She had her little.
他说：“哦，酷。好吧，也许我会再见到你。”Kelly说：“办公室很小。”是的。是的。你注意到她桌子上的东西了吗？什么？她有她那个……
nameplate from the first Christmas party? Yes, I did see that with the flower. Mm-hmm. I thought that was so cute. I did too. Dwight's going to apologize to Phyllis for telling her she should get liposuction on her own dime. He says, I'm going to make it up to you. I have a sale, but it requires two people. Will you go with me? Big sale. Oh, yeah. It's a sure thing. Yeah. I'll give you 40%. I'll split it with you 6040. He says he'll drive. She's like, all right. And then of course, Kelly needs to have this really odd, forced makeout session with Darrell in front of Ryan on purpose. But I want you to know, Jenna, at 26 minutes, 12 seconds, you get a really good shot of Ryan's like his phone earpiece headset thingy. Yeah. Yeah. According to Randy Cordray, our line producer, there was a lengthy discussion about which ear headset
来自第一次圣诞派对的名牌？是的，我看到了那个带花的。嗯哼。我觉得那太可爱了。我也这么觉得。Dwight要向Phyllis道歉，因为他告诉她应该自费去做抽脂手术。他说：“我会补偿你的。我有一个销售机会，但需要两个人。你愿意和我一起去吗？大生意。哦，是的。这是肯定的。是的。我会给你40%。我会和你六四分成。”他说他会开车。她说：“好吧。”然后当然，Kelly需要故意在Ryan面前和Darrell进行这种非常奇怪、强迫的亲热。但我希望你知道，Jenna，在26分12秒，你得到了一个Ryan的耳机听筒的特写。是的。是的。根据我们的制片经理Randy Cordray的说法，关于Ryan应该用哪种耳机……
Ryan should use. He said Phil Shea brought over a tray. He said it looked like 12 to 20. That sounds right. Right? Different versions for them to pick out. That sounds about right. Yeah. They picked a real douchey one. So good job, guys. Let's go to the break room. Jim is having lunch with Michael and Holly. Two things here. Continuity catch. I don't know if you notice, but Michael suddenly does not have a goatee. Oh, yes, they were having issues keeping track. And also, there are a lot of fruit flies in the vending machine. Well, lady, I think it's time for a fruit fly breakdown. Oh, please.
有过长时间的讨论。他说Phil Shea拿来了一个托盘。他说看起来有12到20个。这听起来很对。对吧？不同的版本供他们选择。这听起来很对。是的。他们选了一个非常混蛋的。所以干得好，伙计们。我们去休息室吧。Jim正在和Michael及Holly吃午餐。这里有两件事。连贯性捕捉。我不知道你有没有注意到，Michael突然没有山羊胡了。哦，是的，他们在追踪这些方面遇到了问题。而且，自动售货机里有很多果蝇。好吧，女士，我想是时候进行一次果蝇解析了。哦，拜托。
Angela, we got a lot of mail about the fruit flies. Hit me with your questions, because I have some answers. People wanted to know if they were real, were they CGI. I remember Gene Stupnitsky told me they were real, and they even had a fruit fly wrangler. They were real. Let me tell you everything I learned. about them in the DVD commentary. First of all, this whole bit cost thousands of dollars.
Angela，我们收到了很多关于果蝇的邮件。用你的问题砸我吧，因为我有答案。人们想知道它们是真的吗，是CGI吗。我记得Gene Stupnitsky告诉我它们是真的，他们甚至有一个果蝇驯兽师。它们是真的。让我告诉你我学到的一切。关于它们在DVD评论中的内容。首先，整个片段花费了数千美元。
All right? These fruit flies were from the Florida fruit fly growers, and they were bred specifically for this episode. These type of fruit flies are a sterile type of fruit fly, and they are bred for Florida citrus farms. According to Kelly Cantley, they have a very specific breeding cycle, so they had to schedule, So they had to schedule the fruit flies to be released on a specific day. And Randy, Randy said we had fruit flies for weeks.
好了？这些果蝇来自佛罗里达果蝇种植者，它们是专门为这一集培育的。这种果蝇是一种不育的果蝇，是为佛罗里达柑橘农场培育的。根据Kelly Cantley的说法，它们有非常特定的繁殖周期，所以他们必须安排……所以他们必须安排果蝇在特定的一天释放。Randy说我们有果蝇好几周了。
I remember them. I do too. We'd go in the break room and there would still be a few buzzing around. Yeah, I guess even though they couldn't mate, a lot of them, they really lived beyond their life cycle. Yeah. In addition to these fruit flies reading schedule that we had to plan around, Jenna, Philshay had to time out rotting fruit over the course of eight weeks. Oh my gosh.
我记得它们。我也记得。我们走进休息室，仍然会有几只在嗡嗡作响。是的，我想即使它们不能交配，它们中的许多确实活过了它们的生命周期。是的。除了我们必须计划的这些果蝇繁殖时间表外，Jenna，Phil Shea必须在八周的时间里安排腐烂的水果。天哪。
This fruit had to go through stages of rotting. He had a table set up on our soundstage full of fruit in different stages of rotting for this scene. Lady, I was just about to say that. As you said that, a memory came flooding back into my head of this giant long table where he had created little squares out of tape. Yeah. And each square had a different piece of fruit in it in different stages of rot. Yes. All for this one gag.
这些水果必须经历腐烂的阶段。他在我们的摄影棚里摆了一张桌子，上面摆满了处于不同腐烂阶段的水果，为了这个场景。女士，我正要说那个。当你这么说的时候，一个记忆涌入我的脑海，那张巨大的长桌，他用胶带做成了一个个小方块。是的。每个方块里都有不同腐烂阶段的水果。是的。所有这些都是为了这一个梗。
That is like on camera for like two seconds. I know. Again, like some little throwaway line in the script created all of this production. Florida fruit fly growers, rotted fruit, fruit fly wranglers. Incredible. Shifting gears here over at Pratt, Pam is in the hallway. way, between classes, she's paling around with her new school friends. Alex, played by Rich Summer, is making some jokes.
这在镜头前只出现了两秒钟。我知道。再一次，剧本里的一句随口说的话创造了所有这些制作。佛罗里达果蝇种植者、腐烂的水果、果蝇驯兽师。不可思议。转换话题，在Pratt，Pam在走廊里。在课间，她和她的新学校朋友们在一起。Rich Summer饰演的Alex正在开一些玩笑。
Jim calls. Pam says, I'm going to call you back because I made some friends. Okay, they were trying to make everybody mad. They were trying to make people feel like this art school thing might drive a wedge between Jim and Pam. Now, see, I wasn't worried yet. As I rewatch it, I'm not worried yet. I'm happy that she's making friends. I am too.
Jim打来电话。Pam说：“我会回电给你的，因为我交了一些朋友。”好吧，他们试图让每个人都生气。他们试图让人们觉得这所艺术学校可能会在Jim和Pam之间造成隔阂。现在，看，我还不担心。当我重温它时，我不担心。我很高兴她交到了朋友。我也是。
I do want to say, Pam, what the F with your earrings. This is sassy college, Pam. She's got her updo ponytail. Did you look at the earrings, though? They're like these purple roses. I mean, has this woman never dressed casually? I don't know. I feel like I'm celebrating Pam in this moment.
我确实想说，Pam，你的耳环是怎么回事。这是时髦的大学Pam。她扎着高马尾。你注意看耳环了吗？它们像紫色的玫瑰。我的意思是，这个女人从来没有穿得这么随意过吗？我不知道。我觉得我此刻在赞美Pam。
You're really judging her whole outfit. I guess, you know, you don't have to be too worried about Pam attracting other men with those earrings on. Oh, stop. I don't know. She looked cute. I have to take us back to the bullpen because at 27 minutes, 13 seconds, one of the best scenes of this episode is Phyllis storming in. She is ticked off. Gene Stapnitzky said this is his favorite scene of the episode. I loved it so much. I mean, Dwight drives Phyllis to an abandoned warehouse five miles away and kicks her out of the car. Yeah. He took her money. And her phone. And so she had to walk back. And Dwight says, I bet you burned about a thousand calories. Phyllis is not having it. I think Pissed off Phyllis is my favorite Phyllis.
你真的在评判她整套衣服。我想，你知道，你不用太担心Pam戴着那些耳环吸引其他男人。哦，停下。我不知道。她看起来很可爱。我必须带我们回到办公室，因为在27分13秒，这一集最好的场景之一是Phyllis冲了进来。她气坏了。Gene Stupnitsky说这是他这一集里最喜欢的场景。我太喜欢了。我的意思是，Dwight开车把Phyllis送到五英里外的一个废弃仓库，把她踢下了车。是的。他拿走了她的钱。还有她的手机。所以她不得不走回来。Dwight说：“我打赌你消耗了大约一千卡路里。”Phyllis不吃这一套。我觉得生气的Phyllis是我最喜欢的Phyllis。
It's such a hard call because Pissed off Phyllis is so great. But I do also love like emotionally wounded Phyllis. Like the whole thing that went down with Sue Grafton. Oh gosh. Yes. At the Steentown Mall. Sue Grafton, that was so good too. Well, she calls David Wallace. Mm-hmm. She is done with her. Dwight. Week six of the way in. There is no way in this week. Holly instead reads an official statement from corporate. They're just concerned. You know, this was supposed to be about health and
这很难选，因为生气的Phyllis太棒了。但我确实也喜欢情感受伤的Phyllis。比如Sue Grafton发生的那整件事。哦，天哪。是的。在Steentown购物中心。Sue Grafton，那也太棒了。好吧，她给David Wallace打电话。嗯哼。她受够了Dwight。称重的第六周。这周没有称重。Holly反而读了一份来自总部的官方声明。他们只是很关心。你知道，这本应该是关于健康和……
wellness, and they need to make sure that everyone knows the point of this, like, health kick. In case, the memo wasn't enough, Michael's going to try to help explain it. Oh, yeah, Michael wants to bring it on home with one of his characters. This is how you do. get people's attention, remember? As a little kid, Hoot the Owl came to his elementary school. If you want to get through to someone, you dress up as a character. So enter Michael Clump. Yep. We had a fan question, Angela, from Grayine L. When Michael says he's wearing his sumo suit from Beach Games, was Steve actually wearing his sumo suit underneath his clothes? No. So here's the deal. Alicia, our wardrobe designer, was actually part of the DVD commentary. And she said,
健康的，他们需要确保每个人都知道这次健康热潮的重点。如果备忘录还不够，Michael会试着帮忙解释。哦，是的，Michael想用他的一个角色来总结。这就是你如何……吸引人们注意的方法，记得吗？小时候，猫头鹰Hoot去过他的小学。如果你想和某人沟通，你就打扮成一个角色。所以Michael Clump登场了。是的。Angela，我们有一个来自Grayine L.的粉丝提问。当Michael说他穿着《海滩游戏》里的相扑服时，Steve真的在衣服下面穿着他的相扑服吗？没有。所以情况是这样的。我们的服装设计师Alicia实际上是DVD评论的一部分。她说……
they weren't able to use the sumo suit. They had to buy a special type of suit that went under the sports jacket and pants. And Steve actually had to have two pretty thorough fittings for this whole thing to happen. Wow. I bet Steve got hot. I wonder if they used his air-conditioned vest that you told us about last week. His cooling vests. Yeah.
他们没能使用那件相扑服。他们不得不买一种特殊的衣服，穿在运动夹克和裤子下面。Steve实际上为了让这一切发生，进行了两次相当彻底的试装。哇。我打赌Steve很热。我想知道他们是否用了你上周告诉我们的空调背心。他的冷却背心。是的。
Probably. Well, Michael is leading this whole meeting where he wants to celebrate people's body image, no matter what you look like. and during this meeting he looks over and he notices that Ryan has shaved his goate. Yeah. And he's like, Ryan, did you shave your goate? And Ryan's like, yeah, I did. Well, now all the goatees are going to come off. Well, yeah.
可能吧。好吧，Michael主持了整个会议，他想赞美人们的身体形象，无论你看起来如何。在会议期间，他看了一眼，注意到Ryan刮掉了他的山羊胡。是的。他说：“Ryan，你刮掉山羊胡了吗？”Ryan说：“是的，我刮了。”好吧，现在所有的山羊胡都要刮掉了。好吧，是的。
You know, Michael is trying to get everyone to celebrate how their bodies are different but beautiful. And Michael kneels down to talk to Kelly. You guys, 31 minutes, 21 seconds. Mindy is doing her classic covering her mouth. so you can't see her starting to break. I noticed it too. I noticed it right away. Michael makes Kelly stand up.
你知道，迈克尔正试图让每个人都去赞美彼此身体的独特与美丽。迈克尔跪下来和凯利说话。伙计们，31分21秒。敏迪正在做她经典的捂嘴动作，所以你看不出她快要笑场了。我也注意到了。我一眼就看出来了。迈克尔让凯利站起来。
He wants everyone to look at her and tell her how great she looks. Ryan says she's perfect. Meredith likes her fingernails. Phyllis likes her dress. And Creed says she has a hell of an ass. Yeah. And Kelly's like, what else? I wasn't there.
他想让每个人都看着她，告诉她她看起来有多棒。瑞安说她很完美。梅雷迪思喜欢她的指甲。菲利斯喜欢她的裙子。而克里德说她的屁股真带劲。是啊。凯利问，还有呢？我当时不在那儿。
I was at art school. Yeah. It was such a bummer. There were a lot of things that I missed. Mm-hmm. These were the classic conference room scenes when you guys would be stuck in there for a whole day, maybe two. Oh, yes. We got pretty punchy in there. But one of my favorite talking heads is Phyllis Singh. She wonders what people would like about her. Probably her jugs. Maybe so. Speaking of art school, Pam's in class, and Alex is making her giggle.
我在艺术学校。是啊。真是太扫兴了。我错过了很多事情。嗯。这些是经典的会议室场景，你们会被困在那里一整天，甚至两天。哦，是的。我们在那儿都变得有点疯疯癫癫的。但我最喜欢的访谈之一是菲利斯·辛格。她想知道大家会喜欢她什么。大概是她的胸部吧。也许吧。说到艺术学校，帕姆在课堂上，亚历克斯逗得她咯咯笑。
Flirty, flirt. They even get in trouble. Well, I have a little fun fact. If you listen closely, you can hear her art school professor. saying this. Some blame it on the new air conditioning system. This is what he's talking about. There are these paintings in France called the Lascaux paintings, if I'm pronouncing that correctly. They are ancient cave paintings and they have just faced incredible disturbance since their discovery because they have tourists come through like upwards of like 1,200 tourists a day. They put in air conditioning in this cave. They put in lighting systems to make viewing these paintings more enjoyable, but as a result, lichens, I don't know if I'm pronouncing that
调情，调情。他们甚至惹上了麻烦。嗯，我有个小趣闻。如果你仔细听，你能听到她的艺术学校教授在说这个。有些人把它归咎于新的空调系统。这就是他在谈论的内容。法国有一些画作被称为拉斯科洞窟壁画，如果我发音正确的话。它们是古老的洞穴壁画，自发现以来就遭到了难以置信的破坏，因为每天有超过1200名游客参观。他们在洞穴里安装了空调。他们安装了照明系统，让观看这些画作变得更舒适，但结果是，地衣，我不知道我发音是否正确，但不管地衣是什么，对吧，还有晶体，在20世纪50年代后期开始出现在墙壁上，他们不得不关闭这些洞穴以保护残存的神圣画作。所以当他说，有些人把它归咎于新的空调系统时，他就是在谈论法国的这些洞穴壁画。嗯，那真是很多有用的信息。我只是觉得我们的编剧真的很棒，我们的编剧团队里有人非常非常聪明。是啊。是吉恩吗？是李吗？
correctly, but whatever lightchens are, right, and crystals, they start to appear on the walls in the late 1950s, and they had to close down these caves to preserve what was left of the sacred paintings. So when he says, some blame it on the new air conditioning system, he's talking about these cave paintings in France. Well, that was a lot of good information. I just think it's really, cool that our writers, someone, is very, very smart on our writing staff. Yeah. Was it Jean? Was it Lee?
是别人吗？我不知道。也许是保罗·利伯斯坦，因为我们知道他是个环球旅行家，而且喜欢艺术。有人做了一点挖掘，在那里埋下了一颗种子。是啊。嗯，这个场景与吉姆的访谈并置，让人们很生气。因为帕姆在艺术课上和亚历克斯笑得很开心。然后是吉姆的访谈。
Was it someone else? I don't know. Maybe it was Paul Lieberstein because we know he's quite the world traveler and likes art. Someone did a little digging and planted a little seed there. Yeah. Well, this scene in juxtaposition to Jim's talking head got people fired up. Because here's Pam laughing in art class with Alex. And then there's a gym talking head.
他说夏天过得很好。只要听迈克尔·克伦普讲两个小时。确信我得了溃疡。而且我女朋友住在纽约，我已经10天没见到她了。所以当这一集播出时，人们对帕姆很不满。我记得。我有很多话要说。哦，不。
He says summer's going great. Just listen to Michael Clump for two hours. Convinced I have an ulcer. And my girlfriend lives in New York and I haven't seen her in 10 days. So people were not happy with Pam when this episode aired. I remember. I have a lot to say. Oh, no.
哦，不。嗯，我只想说，当帕姆去艺术学校只待了三个月，当时她还没结婚，也没有孩子，人们就因为吉姆的感受而对她大加指责。后来，当吉姆在没告诉帕姆的情况下投资了一项生意，离开了他的家庭，让帕姆独自照顾他们的两个孩子，而去追逐他的梦想时，人们又因为帕姆对吉姆不够支持而指责她。所以在这些例子中，我只想说，我注意到了很多对帕姆的仇恨。我想称之为性别歧视吗？我想。我想。天哪。
Oh, no. Well, I just want to say that when Pam went to art school for only three months when she was not yet married and didn't have children, people came down real hard. on her because of Jim's feelings. Then, when Jim invested in a business without telling Pam and left his family and left Pam alone to care for their two children while he chased his dreams, people came down on Pam again for not being supportive enough of Jim. So in both of these instances, I just want to say, I noticed a lot of hate for Pam. Do I want to call it sexist? I do. I do. Oh my gosh.
我只想说，帕姆作为一个角色受到了很多审视，我认为是因为她是个女人。嗯。对吧？是啊，那条河很深。它很深，而且会一直延伸到未来的几季。好吧。我们要休息一下吗？我们应该休息一下，因为当我们回来时，我们将进行天气解析。
I just want to say that Pam faced a lot of scrutiny as a character, I think because she was a woman. Mm-hmm. Right? Yeah, that river runs deep. It runs deep, and it's going to run long into some future seasons. Okay. Should we take a break? We should because when we come back, we're going to have a weather breakdown.
天气解析。天气解析。我等不及了。嗯，我们回来了。外面正下着倾盆大雨。屏幕是黑色的，上面写着第七周，8月11日，你只能听到雨声。现在是称重时间。每个人都在仓库里。巨大的仓库门开着，雨正倾盆而下。我不知道为什么需要下雨。我不知道为什么我们需要设定一场大暴雨，嗯？我不知道为什么。也许我们一会儿就会知道了。
A weather breakdown. A weather breakdown. I can't wait. Well, we are back. and it is pouring rain. There is a black screen with the words week seven, August 11th, and you can just hear the rain. Now it's time for the way in. Everyone's in the warehouse. The huge warehouse door is open and it's just coming down. I wonder why it needed to rain. I wonder why we needed to establish a big rainstorm, huh? I don't know why. Maybe we'll find out in a little
嗯，这是假雨。是的，这是经过深思熟虑的。他们想设定这场大暴雨。在我们办公室布景的窗外，通常会有巨大的背景幕，对吧，珍娜？是的。他们带来了你告诉我们的那些雨幕。哦，因为我们有一集迈克尔无法升起敞篷车的车顶，然后车里就下雨了。没错。所以他们带回了那些巨大的窗格，他们可以循环水，看起来就像在下雨，你会在几个场景的背景中看到它，这有助于不断强化外面是雨天。有一件事我要告诉你，有时对于仓库外的这种雨，他们必须为音效部门和剪辑进行调整。但他们说听起来很真实。所以音效部门不需要剪掉假雨。嗯。好吧，就是这样。另外，如果你在记录的话，记得凯利·坎特利在上周的节目中给了我们一份要记录的事情清单，我们现在是两个没留山羊胡的家伙，一个留山羊胡的家伙。迈克尔和瑞安没留山羊胡，德怀特留了山羊胡。没错。他们也在进行第七周的称重，这时霍莉说她已经有三天没收到她那个瑜伽老师约会对象的消息了。
bit. Well, this was fake rain. And yes, this was thought out. They wanted to establish this big rainstorm. Outside of the windows of our set in the bullpen, where normally there would be the big backdrops, right, Jenna? Yep. They brought in those rain panels that you told us about. Oh, because we had an episode where Michael couldn't get the top up on his convertible, and then it rained inside the car. That's right. So they brought back in those big window panes that they were able to sort of re-sucing. cycle water through so it looked like raining and you're going to see it in the backdrop of several scenes that just help keep reinforcing that it is a rainy day out. The one thing I will tell you is that sometimes with this rain like outside the warehouse, they would have to adjust that
是啊。她甚至买了那天晚上的乌鸦乐队演唱会门票，她不知道，他会来吗？他会打电话吗？是啊。达里尔宣布他们减掉了四磅。四磅。与此同时，回到办公室，吉姆和帕姆正在即时通讯上聊天。
for the sound department and editing. But they said it sounded real. So the sound department didn't have to edit out the fake rain. Huh. Well, there you go. Also, if you're keeping track, remember Kelly Cantley in last week's episode gave us a list of things to keep track of, we are now two guys no goatee, one guy goatee. Michael and Ryan, no goate, Dwight with a goate. That's right. They're also having their week seven weigh in, and this is when Holly says she hasn't heard from her yoga teacher date in like three days.
他们正试图弄清楚什么时候能见面。吉姆和他侄子的球赛有冲突。你知道，他们不知道。吉姆说，你为什么不出来跟我吃午饭？是啊，挺随性的。我们在中间见面吧。是啊，在半路见面。我们在休息站见面吧。
Yeah. She had even bought tickets to the counting crows for that night, and she doesn't know, like, is he going to show? Is he going to call? Yeah. And Daryl announces that they've lost four pounds. Four pounds. Meanwhile, back in the bullpen, Jim and Pam, they're chatting on I.M.
那是纽约和斯克兰顿之间的中点。而这段时间，德怀特以为吉姆在谈论他，对吧，他在搞什么鬼。帕姆给吉姆发了即时消息说，哦，顺便说一下，完成了我的暑期项目。吉姆点击了它。你猜那是什么？一张德怀特的照片。这是一个ASCII肖像，代表美国信息交换标准代码，这是一种用于电子通信的字符编码标准。
They're trying to figure out when can they see each other. Jim has a conflict with his nephew's ball game. You know, they don't know. Jim says, why don't you meet me for lunch? Yeah, kind of spontaneous. We'll meet in the middle. Yeah, meet halfway. Let's meet at the rest stop.
ASCII码代表文本、计算机、电信设备和其他设备。嗯，猜猜谁有它的副本？谁？乔亚，她发给我了。天哪。所以我有了帕姆画的德怀特的ASCII肖像。我会把它发到我们的故事里。我喜欢这个。
That's halfway between New York and Scranton. When this whole time, Dwight thinks Jim is talking about him, right, that he's up to something. And Pam, I-M's Jim and says, oh, by the way, finished my summer project. And Jim clicks on it. And guess what's there? A picture of Dwight. It is an ASCII portrait, which stands for American Standard Code for Information Interchange, which is a character encoding standard for electronic communication.
嗯，我喜欢它，因为它显示帕姆在学校里学到了东西。嗯。她不只是在调情。不，她不是，大家。她很认真。她戴上紫色的花朵耳环，扎着马尾辫去上课。霍莉进去找迈克尔，她想让他知道他们只输给尤蒂卡八磅。
ASCII codes represent text and computers, telecommunication equipment, and other devices. Well, guess who has a copy of it? Who? Joya, and she sent it to me. Oh, my gosh. So I have Pam's A-S-C-I-I portrait of Dwight. I'll put it in our stories. I love that.
迈克尔说，等一下，我们还有一天的时间。也许如果他们真的拼了，他们调高暖气，穿上垃圾袋，也许他们能做到。嗯，安迪立刻就加入了。他穿上了他的垃圾袋。他说他不输比赛。他要么赢，要么因为比赛不公平而退出。嗯。凯利没参加。
Well, I like it because it shows that Pam is learning things in school. Mm-hmm. She's not just flirting. No, she's not, everyone. She's taking it seriously. She's putting on her purple flower earrings and marching her ponytail into class. Holly goes in to talk to Michael and she wants him to know that they have lost to Utica by only eight pounds.
她正在吃披萨。安迪和安吉拉之间的婚礼筹备工作并没有停止。安吉拉说，嘿，顺便说一下，她问得非常客气，第一支舞能不能跳《小鼓手男孩》，那是她最喜欢的歌。安迪说，可以，他已经预订了他的阿卡贝拉组合。哦，是的。甚至更好的是，他们的最后一首歌能不能是《小鼓手男孩》，他的阿卡贝拉组合会为你唱这首歌。是啊，麻烦来了，96届毕业生。他说，亲爱的，你会喜欢这些家伙的。
And Michael's like, wait a second, we have to the end of the day. Maybe if they really go for it, they crank up the heat, they're going to wear trash bags, maybe they can get there. Well, Andy's into it immediately. He puts on his trash bags. He says he does not lose competitions. He wins them or he quits because they're unfair. Mm-hmm. Kelly is not participating.
卡尔1号，卡尔2号，西兰花罗伯，备用肋骨，杜比，午餐盒，博纳冠军，那就是我。普比·刘易斯和新闻乐队，跳房子，叮当，叮当，还有三明治。是啊。他们将集体担任他的伴郎。是啊。猜猜谁在传呼德怀特？哦，是的。现在，如果我没记错的话，安吉拉，NBC建立了一个网站。
She's having some pizza. The wedding planning has not stopped between Andy and Angela. Angela says, hey, she asks very nicely, by the way, if the first dance can be to Little Drummer Boy, her favorite song. Andy's like, yeah, he's already booked his Acapella Group. Oh, yeah. It's even better than can their last song be to Little Drummer Boy, his Acapella Group is going to sing it for you. Yeah, here comes trouble, class of 96. And he's like, sweetheart, you're going to love these guys.
为安迪和安吉拉的婚礼。你还记得吗？它现在已经不在线了，但你还记得吗？我记得，我问过乔亚这件事。她发给我安吉拉和安迪婚礼网站的主页照片，上面有他们的婚礼礼物登记处，还有安迪为“麻烦来了”组合制作的试镜视频，想让他们成为婚礼乐队。哇。我都有。我会把它发到故事里。我都有。但我得给你读一下登记处里的物品，拜托。乔亚说，笑话是安迪会列出一些东西，然后安吉拉会列出与安迪列出的东西截然相反的东西。好吧。所以看看你能不能猜出谁在登记处放了什么。歌唱机ISM 370卡拉OK带iPod底座。降噪耳机。暮光之城厚实、不透明的浴帘，防盗浴室门锁。谦虚更衣屏风。男女款小猫睡衣，儿童小号和男士大号。小猫躺椅。三块康奈尔大学大红终极户外地毯。玛丽·奥斯蒙德灵感长椅。装饰性墙帽和盖蒂日历。哇。这就是NBC.com婚礼网站上他们的登记清单。是时候了。是时候了。吉姆和帕姆，他们要在休息站见面。在倾盆大雨中，我们有很多关于它的分享。珍娜，你在那儿。我不在。我有一些很棒的DVD评论内容要和你们分享，来自我们的剧组，但你应该接着说。嗯，这就是求婚场景。是的。吉姆单膝跪地，向帕姆求婚。她完全惊呆了。他们在加油站。你知道，他本应该等她从艺术学校回来，但他说是他等不及了。她完全被搞糊涂了。是啊。
Carl 1, Carl 2, broccoli rob, spare rib, dooby, lunchbox, boner champ, that's me. Pubey Lewis and the News, hopscotch, jingle, jangle, and sandwich. Yeah. And they're collectively going to be his best man. Yeah. Guess who's paging Dwight? Oh, yeah. Now, if I remember correctly, Angela, NBC built a website.
你真的看得出她完全没想到。事实上，场景开始时，她说，嘿，这不是半路。我开得更远了。就像，她的心思根本不在那儿。是啊。但她答应了，他们接吻了。所以首先，我只想让你们知道，格雷格和我们谈过这件事。他说他真的希望吉姆向帕姆求婚是在季首播中。
for Andy and Angela's wedding. Do you remember that? It's not live anymore, but do you remember that? I do, and I asked Joya about it. She sent me the homepage photo of Angela and Andy's wedding website, complete with their wedding gift registry, and the audition video that Andy put together of Here Comes Trouble to be their wedding band. Wow. I have all of it. I'll put it in stories. I have all of it. And I want to read to you, though, the items on the registry, please. So Joya said the joke was that Andy would list something and then Angela would list something in stark opposition to what Andy had listed. Okay. So see if you can guess who put what on the registry. The singing machine ISM 370 karaoke with iPod Doc. Noise cancelling headphones. Twilight Thick, non-seathing
他认为，第一，这会出人意料。你通常在季末求婚。对。所以他认为这会是一个真正的震撼。确实如此，珍娜，我甚至记得在剧本朗读会上，你知道，我们在这个减肥故事上花了很多心思。而帕姆在艺术学校，我没预料到。不。而且我们在上一季一直在铺垫。
through shower curtain, deadbolt bathroom door lock. Modesty changing screen. His and hers Kitty Cat PJs, kids small and men's size large. Kitty Cat Shays Lounge. Three Cornell Big Red Ultimate Outdoor Rugs. Marie Osmond Inspiration Bench. Decorative wall hat and Getty's calendar. Wow. That's what was on their registry on the NBC.com wedding site. It's time. It's time. Jim and Pam, they're going to meet up at the rest stop. In the pouring rain, we have a lot to share about it. Jenna, you were there. I was not. I have some fantastic DVD commentary stuff to share with you from our crew, but you should take it away. Well, this is the proposal scene. Yes. Jim gets down on one knee and he proposes to Pam. She's totally shocked. They're at a gas station. You know, he was supposed to wait until she got back. from art school, but he says he couldn't wait. She's completely thrown. Yeah.
他说他还想通过在一个非常普通的地方求婚来让人们感到意外。所以他想让它感觉特别，但也想让它感觉像是吉姆没有经过太多计划就做出的决定。嗯。所以格雷格认为这个场景的理想地点是斯克兰顿和纽约之间高速公路旁的一个加油站，在雨中，他们以格雷格·丹尼尔斯小时候在梅里特大道旅行时去过的一个休息站为原型。我们并没有真正飞到那个地点。
You can really tell she had no idea. In fact, the beginning of the scene, she's like, hey, this is not halfway. I drove further. Like, she's, her head is so not in that place. Yeah. But she says yes, and they kiss. So first of all, I just want you guys to know that Greg spoke with us about this. He said that he really wanted Jim's proposal to Pam to be in the season premiere.
这是最疯狂的部分。他们在百思买的停车场里建了这个，我其实去过很多次。他们做的是使用谷歌街景捕捉梅里特大道旁一个真实加油站的图像。然后利用这些图像，他们把它建在停车场里以匹配。他们花了大约九天时间建造它。为了制造高速公路交通的错觉，他们建了一个环绕加油站布景的四车道圆形赛道。他们在赛道的另一边架设了摄像机，
He thought, number one, that would be unexpected. You usually end seasons with proposals. Right. So he thought this would be a real shock. And it was, Jenna, I even remember at the table read, you know, we had so much going on with this weight loss story. And Pam at art school, I didn't see it coming. No. And we'd been teasing it all last season.
他们让汽车以每小时55英里的速度绕着它开。然后他们增加了雨，倾盆大雨，这些巨大的造雨机。我们的制片经理兰迪·科德雷说他们有大约35名精密驾驶员。他们驾驶的不仅是汽车，还有半挂卡车。当我们站在那个布景上时，你能感觉到这些车飞驰而过带来的风。这真是太疯狂了。但在我们拍摄完场景后，他们不得不雇佣一家特效公司把背景涂掉，因为背景是加州的群山。
He said he also wanted to throw people off by having it in a very ordinary location. So he wanted to feel special, but he also. also wanted it to feel like Jim made the decision without a whole lot of planning. Mm-hmm. So Greg thought that the ideal location for this scene would be a gas station along the freeway between Scranton and New York, in the rain, and they based the rest stop on one that Greg Daniels had traveled to as a kid along the Merritt Parkway. We did not actually fly to this location.
所以他们不得不把山涂掉，放上一些树，看起来像东海岸的树。最后，这是整部剧拍摄过程中最昂贵的一个场景。它持续了52秒，花费了25万美元。我的天哪。我的天哪。哇。是啊。所以不到一分钟的屏幕时间花了四分之一百万美元。天哪。嗯，听着，我们的剧组在DVD评论中深入讨论了这一刻。显然有很多和你刚才分享的非常相似的事情。所以在经过几个月的勘景和会议后，是我们的外景经理凯尔·亚历山大找到了这个巨大的铺装停车场。我想它是在洛斯费利斯大道附近。是的。几英亩的铺装
This is the insane part. They built this in the parking lot of a Best Buy that I have been to many times, actually. What they did was they used Google Street View to capture images of a real gas station along the Merit Parkway. And then using those images, they built it to match in this parking lot. It took them about nine days to build it. To create the illusion of highway traffic, they built. a four-lane circular racetrack around the gas station set. They set up cameras on the other side of this raceway,
地面，如果他们要建一个赛道，这正是他们所需要的，对吧？是啊。所以这些车可以绕圈。现在，根据兰迪·科德雷的说法，它之所以是一个如此巨大、巨大、巨大的停车场，是因为它是一个铺了水泥的有毒废物场。什么？是的。显然，多年前，有一个旧的陶瓷厂之类的东西把铅漆废物埋在了地下，所以他们不得不密封并覆盖它。所以，安吉拉，我只是想确保我们承认你刚才给我们的信息意味着吉姆和帕姆，我们心爱的Jam，是在一个前有毒废物堆上订婚的。荧光Jam。我的意思是，太糟糕了。嗯，这就是他们在DVD评论中分享的内容。那是很久以前的事了。他们把它密封起来了。这是一个巨大的停车场。显然现在那里有一个百思买。嗯，迈克尔·加伦伯格在DVD评论中分享说，他建造的整个布景中他最喜欢的东西之一是玻璃门后的饮料。
and they had cars drive around it at 55 miles an hour. Then they added rain, pouring down on us, these giant rain machines. Our production manager, Randy Cordray, said they had about 35 precision drivers. They were driving not just cars, but like semi-trucks. When we were standing there on that set, you could feel the wind of these cars speeding past you. It was so, so bonkers. But after we shot the scene, they had to hire a special effects company to paint out the background because the background were these California mountains.
事实上，那是一张巨大的照片。它是泡沫芯纸上的喷墨打印。看起来棒极了。在38分32秒有一个很棒的镜头。就在吉姆和帕姆身后，我永远不会知道那些饮料是一张照片。是啊。这是一个令人难以置信的布景。是啊。
And so they had to paint out the mountains and put in some trees like East Coast looking trees. In the end, this was the single most expensive. scene ever shot during the entire run of the show. It lasts 52 seconds and it costs $250,000. Oh my Lord. Oh my Lord. Wow. Yeah. So a quarter of a million dollars for less than one minute of screen time. Oh my gosh. Well, listen, they talked in depth our crew about this moment in the DVD commentary. Several, obviously very similar things as what you just shared. So after months and months of scouting and meetings, it was our location manager, Kyle Alexander, who found this enormous paved parking lot. I guess it was off Los Felis Boulevard. Yep. Acres and acres of paved
真的要向我们的布景设计团队和施工人员致敬。他们简直太棒了。这是令人难以置信的。关于这个场景的另一个争论，我相信你们知道，是有声音还是没声音。这是一个巨大的、巨大的争论。格雷格无法下定决心。他们准备了两个版本，一个在求婚时有声音，一个没有。字面上，我的意思是，杰克在DVD评论中分享，杰克·奥斯特，直到播出那天，那是播出日期，格雷格还在试图决定。这太搞笑了，因为我隐约记得这一点，但我们每次都说了台词。是啊。所以争论仅仅是吉姆和帕姆是否还戴着麦克风，你可以听到我们的对话，或者吉姆和帕姆没戴麦克风，你
ground, which is what they needed if they were going to build a racetrack, basically, right? Yeah. So these cars could loop around. Now, according to Randy Cordray, the reason why it was such a massive, massive, massive parking lot is because it was a paved over toxic waste site. What? Yes. Apparently, years and years and years ago, there was an old, like, ceramics plant or something that had buried lead paint waste into the ground, so they had to seal it and cover it. So, Angela, I just want to make sure that we acknowledge that the information you've just given us means that Jim and Pam, our beloved jam, got engaged at a former toxic waste dump. Fluorescent jam. I mean, yikesy. Well, this is what they shared in the DVD commentary. It was a long time ago. They sealed it up. It's a giant parking lot. Apparently there's a best buy there now. Well, Michael Gallenberg shares on the DVD commentary, one of his favorite things that he built of this whole set was the drinks behind the glass doors.
听不到。所以我们每次都说了台词。并不是说写了两个不同的场景，有或没有对话。只是能不能听到而已。是啊。我不认为约翰和我知道这个大争论，因为我们每次都在说我们的台词。是啊。我喜欢能听到它。我认为你能听到它很重要。是啊。我还有几件事要分享，希望不会粉碎你们对这一刻的记忆。就像你说的，树是数字放回去的，对吧？它们是东海岸的树。它们是由星际之门数字放进去的。还有另一件事是一个很大的问号，关于他们如何做这个，那就是雨。他们怎么做雨？他们真的考虑过数字制作，在后期制作中添加它，
It's in fact one humongous giant photo. It was an inkjet print on foam core paper. It looks amazing. And there's a great shot at 38 minutes, 32 seconds. Right behind Jim and Pam, I would have never known that those drinks were a photo. Yeah. It was an incredible set. Yeah.
但保罗·费格非常非常反对。他希望雨感觉尽可能真实。我们可以感觉到雨。我的意思是，有，你知道，它是。我不知道是不是只是车带来的风。我不记得有风机，但我确实记得雨打在我们身上。我的意思是，即使它是一个前有毒废物堆，即使它是一个百思买停车场。是啊，就像在那里真的很浪漫。你知道，这很有趣。加油站，它只是一个门面。如果你进去，它就像一个假货。你穿过门，然后你就像看着树。它没有背面什么的。但它感觉很神奇。确实如此。拍摄那个场景太有趣了。
Really just kudos to our set design team and our construction guys. They just crushed it. It was incredible. The one other debate about this scene, which I'm sure you know, was whether to have sound or no sound. This was a huge, huge debate. Greg could not make up his mind. They had two versions ready to go, one with sound during the proposal and one without. And literally, I mean, Jake shared on the DVD commentary, Jake oust, that up until the day of airing, it was the air date, Greg was still trying to decide. It's so funny because I vaguely remember that, but we spoke dialogue every time. Yeah. So the debate was just simply whether Jim and Pam were still wearing their microphones and you could hear our dialogue or Jim and Pam weren't wearing their microphones and you
我的意思是，我觉得我们第一条就拍好了。也许我们拍了几条。但我的记忆是我们在那儿没待多久，我们很早就拍好了。这是一个很酷的时刻。这是一个非常神奇的时刻。嗯，当大家准备再次称重时，吉姆迟到了。然后他浑身湿透地出现了。而且非常开心。
couldn't. So we said dialogue every time. It wasn't like there were two different scenes that were written with or without dialogue. It was just whether or not you could hear it. Yeah. I don't think John and I knew about this big debate because we were just saying our lines every time. Yeah. I liked being able to hear it. I think it was important that you heard it. Yeah. I have a few more things to share that hopefully won't shatter your memories of this moment. Like you said, the trees were digitally put back in, right? They are East Coast trees. They were put in digitally by Stargate. And here was the other thing that was a big, big question mark about how they do this, was the rain. How do they do the rain? And they really considered doing it digitally, adding it in post-production,
非常开心。我有点难过，他们订婚后没能一起度过整个晚上。我想帕姆只是不得不开车回学校。我知道。但吉姆太开心了。霍莉决定这个瑜伽男永远不会给她打电话。迈克尔说，你知道吗？
but Paul Feig was very, very against it. He wanted the rain to feel as real as possible. And we could feel the rain. I mean, there were, you know, it was. I don't know if it was just the wind from the cars. I don't remember there being wind machines, but I do remember the rain hitting us. And I mean, even though it was a former toxic waste dump and even though it was a- That's by parking lot. Yeah, just like it was actually to be there really romantic. You know, it was funny. The gas station, it was just a front. If you went in, it was like a faky fake. You go through the door and then you're just like looking at trees. It didn't have a back or anything. But it felt magical. It did. And it was so much fun to shoot that scene.
我会从你那儿买乌鸦乐队的票。她说，真的吗？每个人都认为这会导致迈克尔主动提出和她一起去。我以为他们会去约会。不。迈克尔撕碎了票。像绅士一样。就像他在拯救约会一样。
I mean, I feel like we got it on the first take. And maybe we did a few. But my memory is that we weren't there long, that we got it pretty early. And it was a cool moment. It's a really magical moment. Well, when the gang is ready to weigh in again, Jim is late. And then he shows up soaking wet. And so happy.
她很困惑。我们收到了一些来自艾米丽·G的邮件。好吧。她是这么说的。在几个音乐会场地工作过，我想让你知道，如果你丢失或损坏了音乐会门票，你可以带着你的带照片身份证件去场地的售票处，有人会为你重新打印。哦。她说，我希望霍莉知道那是一个选择。哦，那很高兴知道。
So happy. I was a little sad that they didn't get to spend the whole evening together after getting engaged. I guess Pam just had to drive back to school. I know. But Jim is so happy. Holly decides that this yoga guy is never going to call her. And Michael says, you know what?
是啊。看起来霍莉不知道。不。我不知道。嗯，现在我们都知道了。现在我们都知道了。谢谢你，艾米丽。是啊。
I'll buy the counting crows tickets from you. And she's like, really? Everybody thinks this is like going to lead to Michael offering to go with her. I thought they were going to have a date. No. Michael rips up the tickets. Like gallantly. Like he's saving the date.
最后，邓德·米夫林没有赢得减肥比赛。斯坦利减掉了七磅。是啊。他说他无论如何都要休假五天。是啊。现在是第八周了。托比在哥斯达黎加的一家医院病房里待了第五周。哦，可怜的托比，伙计们，还记得吗？
And she's confused. We got some mail from Emily G. Okay. Here's what she said. Having worked at several concert venues, I wanted to let you know that if you lose or damage your concert tickets, you can go to a venue's box office with your photo ID and someone will reprint them for you. Oh. She said, I hope Holly knew that was an option. Oh, that's good to know.
托比和帕姆有过奇怪的时刻，所以他搬到了哥斯达黎加。在像他第一天，还是哪天，是第三天吗？第三天。他去玩了高空滑索。然后他摔断了脖子。是啊。他甚至还没去过海滩。你注意到医院病房里的电视在放什么了吗？是的，我注意到了。那是《明星伙伴》的“拥抱一下，婊子”那一集。那是迈克尔在《政变》中引用的《明星伙伴》那一集。嗯，我有一个关于托比医院病房的小地点解析。给我。它也是在南加州大学拍摄的。哦！是啊，当他们在那里拍摄帕姆的艺术学校时，他们使用了南加州大学电视舞台大楼，南加州大学问是否有八名电影系学生可以实习并在那天帮忙。他们在所有不同的部门都有实习生，我们的剧组说他们做得非常出色。这太酷了。嗯。在我们走之前，我只想向托比隔壁床上的那个人致敬。
Yeah. It didn't seem like Holly knew. No. I didn't know. Well, now we all know. Now we all know. Thank you, Emily. Yeah.
他是一个背景演员，安吉拉，我非常努力地想弄清楚他是谁，因为他太搞笑了。在托比说话的时候，他一直盯着摄像机看。这太棒了。我看了三遍。我想，这家伙怎么能在没有台词的情况下做得这么好？我印象太深刻了。我们无法弄清楚他是谁。我们联系了几个人。
In the end, Dunder Mifflin did not win the weight loss competition. Stanley lost seven pounds. Yeah. He says he's going to take off five days anyway. Yeah. And now it's week eight. Toby is on his fifth week in a hospital room in Costa Rica. Oh, poor Toby guys, remember?
是的。我检查了所有你能检查的地方。他在这一集中没有署名。出色的工作。干得漂亮。伙计们，这就是减肥第二部分。有很多朋友要感谢，感谢他们帮助我们把这一集带给你们。首先，参与DVD评论的剧组人员，兰迪·科德雷，迈克尔
Toby had his weird moment with Pam, so he moved to Costa Rica. And on like his first day, or day, was it like day three? Day three. He went ziplining. And he broke his neck. Yeah. He hasn't even been to the beach. Did you notice what was playing on the TV in the hospital room? Yes, I did. It is the hug-it-out, bitch, episode of entourage. That is the episode of entourage that Michael quotes in the coup. Well, I have a little location breakdown for you about Toby's hospital room. Give it to me. It was also filmed at USC. Oh! Yeah, while they were there filming Pam's art school, They used the USC television stage building, and USC asked if eight of their film students could intern and help that day. They had interns in all of the different departments, and our crew said they did a phenomenal job. That is so cool. Mm-hmm. Before we go, I just want to give a shout out to whoever the guy is in the bed next to Toby.
加伦伯格，布莱恩·惠特尔，尼克·卡博内，本·帕特里克，艾丽西亚·雷克拉夫特，凯利·坎特利，还有杰克·奥斯特。太棒了。最好的评论。如果你喜欢幕后信息，这真的非常值得一听。还有詹姆斯·O·凯里，感谢我们一直用问题烦你。是啊，我们确实烦他了。我们确实烦了。还有乔亚·巴尔福。天哪。我很高兴分享所有关于安吉拉和安迪的NBC.com网站的东西。还有格雷格·丹尼尔斯。谢谢。还有保罗·费格提供的音频片段。我保证不会太打扰你，保罗·费格。
He was a background performer, Angela, I tried so hard to figure out who this is because he is so funny. He just stares into the camera the whole time Toby is talking. It is so good. I watched it three times. I was like, how is this guy doing such a great job with no words? I was so impressed. We couldn't figure out who he was. We reached out to several people.
嗯，我们可能会。我知道。我为什么要做出那个承诺？但我们非常感谢我们的演职人员。我们希望你们喜欢这一集。我们即将开启新的一季。我们下周会回来。我们肯定会。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。这一集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯。我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Yes. And I checked everywhere you can check. He is uncredited in the episode. Phenomenal job. Way to crush it. And you guys, that was a weight loss part two. There's so many folks to thank for helping us get this episode out to you. First of all, our crew that participated in the DVD commentary, Randy Cordray, Michael
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。女士，你有没有投资过什么东西，起初看起来非常棒，但后来却名不副实？我曾经买过一件那种花哨的夹克，在店里看起来棒极了，但我穿出去一次后，意识到它并不舒服，现在它只是躺在我的衣柜里积灰。LinkedIn有一个词来形容它。Bullspend。Bullspend是指你为了看起来很棒的数字而优化，印象、覆盖率、反应。但后来这些
Gallenberg, Brian Whittle, Nick Carbone, Ben Patrick, Alicia Raycraft, Kelly Cantley, and Jake oust. Amazing. Best commentary. Really such a good listen if you love behind the scenes information. And James O. Carey for letting us bug you with questions. Yeah, we did. We did bug him. We did. Enjoy a Balfour. Oh my gosh. I'm so excited to share all of that NBC.com website, stuff about Angela and Andy. And then Greg Daniels. Thank you. And also, Paul Fieg for that audio clip. I promise not to bother you too much, Paul Feeke.
数字并没有真正推动收入。投资于那些对你的首席财务官来说真正好看的东西。LinkedIn广告产生了最高的广告支出回报率，占所有主要广告网络的121%。你可以通过定位公司、行业、职位等来接触正确的买家。所以，停止Bullspend。在LinkedIn上做广告，这个网络为你工作。在LinkedIn广告上为你的第一个活动花费250美元，并为下一个活动获得250美元的积分。只需访问LinkedIn.com/office。那是LinkedIn.com/office。条款和条件适用。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
Well, we probably will. I know. Why am I making that promise? But we appreciate our casting crew so much. We hope you enjoyed this one. And we are kicking off season. We'll be back for more next week. We sure will. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Juerkins. And our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
嗯，我们大概会吧。我知道。我为什么要做出那个承诺呢？但我们非常感谢我们的选角团队。希望你们喜欢这一集。我们即将开启新的一季。下周我们会回来带来更多内容。我们一定会回来的。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯饮品。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》由Odyssey呈现，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·尤金斯。我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是莫莉·纽金特。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Lady, have you ever invested in something that seemed really amazing at first, but then did not live up to the hype? I once got this kind of fancy jacket that looked amazing in the store, but then I wore it out once and I realized it was not comfortable and now it just lives in my closet collecting dust. LinkedIn has a word for that. Bullspend. Bullspend is when you optimize for numbers that look great, impressions, reach, reactions. But then those
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。女士，你有没有投资过什么起初看起来非常棒，但后来却名不副实的东西？我曾经买过一件看起来很高级的夹克，在店里看的时候棒极了，但我穿出去一次后发现它一点也不舒服，现在它只能躺在我的衣柜里积灰。LinkedIn对此有一个词：Bullspend（虚假支出）。Bullspend是指你为了那些看起来很漂亮的数字——曝光量、触达率、互动量——进行优化。但随后这些
numbers don't actually drive revenue. Invest in what actually looks good to your CFO. LinkedIn ads generate the highest ROAS, 121% of all major ad networks. You can reach the right buyers by targeting company, industry, job title, and more. So cut the bullspend. Advertise on LinkedIn, the network that works for you. Spend $250 on your first campaign on LinkedIn ads and get a $250 credit for the next one. just go to LinkedIn.com slash office. That's LinkedIn.com slash office. Terms and conditions apply. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
数字并不能真正带来收入。投资那些能让你的首席财务官真正看好的东西。LinkedIn广告产生的广告支出回报率（ROAS）最高，在所有主要广告网络中占比121%。你可以通过定位公司、行业、职位等来触达正确的买家。所以，停止虚假支出吧。在LinkedIn上投放广告，这是一个为你服务的网络。在LinkedIn广告上首次投放250美元的广告活动，即可获得250美元的下一次广告抵用金。只需访问LinkedIn.com/office。即LinkedIn.com/office。条款和条件适用。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。